sehr verehrte Damen und Herren der
Medien der Herr Vizekanzler Werner
Kogler und die Frau Bundesministerin
Claudia Tanner haben zum heutigen
Medientermin geladen und es geht in
Wahrheit um den Sport der Sport beim
Bundesheer ist
eng verknüpfte mit dem Militär der Sport
ist die Basis des Soldaten und
grundbediener beim heeressportzentrum
sind in Wahrheit die Basis des
Leistungssports
heute wird berichtet über die Steigerung
die Vermehrung der Grundwehrdiener im
Bereich des nächsten Jahres beim
heeressportzentrum ich dafür gehen und
Vizekanzler ja vielen Dank danke auch
für Interesse Frau Bundesminister
geschätzte anwesende
der Sport so ist es und das Bundesheer
haben eine enge Verbindung gerade eben
dürfen wir das Erleben wenn wir die
Einkleidung der
olympiadteilnehmerinnen und
olympi-teilnehmer vornehmen oder auch
die Verabschiedung und insofern ist das
ja schon eine traditionelle Verbindung
die auch immer dazu beigetragen hat dass
Österreich im Leistungs- und dem
Spitzensport hier weit über die Größe
des Landes oder die Einwohnerzahl hinaus
es sind zumindest machen Bereichen sehr
sehr erfolgreich ist jetzt haben wir
eineinhalb Jahre Pandemie nicht ganz
hinter uns es hat überall große
Einschnitte gegeben erst recht im Sport
und Bewegungsbereich wir bedauern dass
wir in vielen Lebensbereichen
Kinderschule etc wird auch wichtig was
die gesamte gesundheitliche Situation
betrifft aber und da kommen wir gleich
zum ausschlaggebenden Punkt für hier und
heute es war natürlich für viele die
Richtung Spitzensport drängen auch sehr
schwierige Zeit obwohl wir für die
Leistungs- und Spitzensportler besondere
Regelungen erlassen konnten so hat es
doch ein Wettbewerben gemangelt in
erster Linie logischerweise und deshalb
viele die Leistungsnachweise nicht
unbedingt erbringen konnten die sonst
notwendig wären um bei den 150 Plätzen
der Grundwehrdiener im
leistungssportzentrum des Bundesheeres
hier zu sein und das glaube ich das
glaube ich verdient dann eine
Korrektur zugunsten der angehenden
Spitzensportler und da bin jetzt
wirklich sehr sehr dankbar
und wenn du mir hast drücke ich an die
Frau Bundesministerin das eine Idee die
aus dem Comeback stronger Programm
Comeback stronger für den Sport und für
Bewegungen Österreich gekommen ist hier
übernommen wurde nämlich zu den 150
Plätzen für die Grundwehrdiener 20 dazu
zu nehmen das wird dann ab jetzt oder in
den ins nächste Jahr hinein abgewickelte
Bundesminister wird das sicher näher
ausführen aber die Grundidee kam aus dem
Sport wurde
herangetragen und ich bin froh dass das
derart unkompliziert aufgenommen wurde
und darf mir also an der Stelle noch mal
bedanken und übergeben
ja danke vielmals
Medien
wir leben in schweren Zeiten die
Pandemie ist angesprochen waren aber
irgendwie kommt man auch nicht umhin
nach den furchtbaren Unwetterschäden das
gegeben hat auch daran zu denken und
insbesondere auch daran zu erinnern dass
unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten vom
Grundwert in über das Kaderpersonal bis
zur Miliz auch hier in ganz Österreicher
im Einsatz sind das war auch während
pandemiezeiten so und das vergangene
Jahr war ein unglaublich forderndes und
es waren auch die
heeressportlerinnen und Sportler die von
am Beginn an der Pandemie im Einsatz
waren und auch da geholfen haben es ist
mir ein Bedürfnis ja Vizekanzler Danke
zu sagen für die Initiative Comeback
stronger und unser Beitrag den wir als
Verteidigungsressort leisten können ist
vielleicht ein kleiner aber in Wahrheit
mit dieser zusätzlichen Möglichkeit der
20 Plätze schon auch einer bei vielen
jungen Sportlern wieder die Möglichkeit
gibt auch eine soziale Absicherung zu
bekommen zum einen seinen Dienst zu
leisten und der Republik und auf der
anderen Seite auch dem Leistungssport
nachzugehen und der oberste hat schon
angesprochen der Sport spielt im
Bundesheer eine unglaublich wichtige
Rolle und wenn du Herr Vizekanzler
angesprochen hast die Olympischen Spiele
70 Prozent der Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmer die die Olympia dabei sind
werden ja auch vom österreichischen
Bundesheer eben gestellt sind unsere
heeressportlerinnen und heeressportler
und daher glaube ich dass dieser Beitrag
den wir hier setzen können mit den
zusätzlichen Plätzen ein sehr wichtiger
ist vielleicht zu den generellen Zahlen
noch es sind 450 in etwa
Leistungssportlerinnen und Sportler
denen wir hier die sozialrechtliche
Absicherung geben können und die auf der
anderen Seite aber dafür sorgen dass wir
immer wieder große Erfolge in den
verschiedensten Bereichen auch feiern
können im
heeressportzentrum warum ist das so ich
glaube das gerade
der Beruf des Soldaten der Soldatin mit
den Herausforderungen die der
Leistungssportler eben hat sehr vieles
zu tun hat und sehr vieles gemeinsam hat
das beginnt bei der Disziplin geht um
die Kampfbereitschaft führt auch zudem
immer wieder aufzustehen auch wenn
Misserfolge dann da sind und daher
glaubt der Bass auch ganz gut dazu
Comeback stronger jetzt auch mit
zusätzlichen 20 Plätzen für unsere
Grundwehrdiener dankeschön
sehr verehrte Medienvertreter im
Hintergrund sehen sie sieben
Grundwehrdiener die in Uniform dastehen
weil sie Soldaten sind und sie haben
auch ihre Sportgeräte dabei das heißt
sie sehen auch die Vielfalt alle
Sportarten Mannschaftssportarten bis zu
einzelsportarten wie Fechten etc wir
haben jetzt vor ihnen die Möglichkeit zu
geben Fragen zu stellen anschließend
würden wir eine Möglichkeit geben zum
Gruppenfoto und dann das diese diesen
Pressetermin beschließen
gibt es Fragen bitte
könnten Sie uns sagen in welchem Bereich
ist die momentan das Bundesheer
eingesetzt
bei den Unwetterkatastrophen und wie
viele Soldaten sind im Einsatz ja wir
sind nach wie vor im Einsatz in Hallein
ganz intensiv das sind insbesondere die
Pioniere die hier mit den aufräumen
arbeiten auch beschäftigt sind es sind
auch in Niederösterreicher Soldaten im
Einsatz wenn sie jetzt nur die
unwettersituation ansprechen dann sind
es derzeit 80 Soldatinnen Soldaten die
im Einsatz sind österreichweit aber man
darf ja auch nicht vergessen wir haben
immer auch die Notwendigkeit dass wir
Soldaten und Züge auch bereit halten
sollte eben eine zusätzliche Anforderung
der zuständigen Behörden auch kommen
[Applaus]
passt vielleicht insofern auch ganz gut
immer auch natürlich mit dem notwendigen
Gerät das ist derzeit insbesondere was
auch schweres Gerät anbelangt eben
seitens der Pioniere die Notwendigkeit
die eine oder andere Brücke eben wieder
herzustellen dann auch Muren
verglausungen auch hier bei der
Bewältigung mitzuhelfen was man nicht da
vergessen darf ist das auch eben Zuluft
etwas notwendiger sein kann das sind zum
einen Erkundung Erkundungsflüge die im
Vorfeld eben notwendig waren das war ja
jetzt auch am Wochenende so bevor
sozusagen auch die Züge dann in Gang
gesetzt worden sind und zusätzlich haben
wir nach wie vor in Zusammenhang mit der
Pandemie an die 500 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten an den verschiedensten Stellen
im Einsatz das sind nach wie vor noch
Testungen das sind logistische
Unterstützungen was die Impfungen
anbelangt und natürlich darf man auch
nicht nicht vergessen dass die die
Zuständigkeit auch bei den
sicherheitspolizeilichen Grenzkontrollen
nach wie vor eben gegeben ist das ist
sind nach der heutigen morgenmeldung in
etwa 900 Soldatinnen und Soldaten die
diesbezüglich im Einsatz sind
sie sehen also Sport und Bundesheer
passen gut zusammen weil so unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten sind natürlich
müssen fit sein um auch solche Aufgaben
bewältigen zu können gibt es weitere
Fragen
an den
was kann die Regierung angesichts der
Umweltkatastrophe machen wie was gibt es
dafür Pläne für Hilfe und und
Unterstützung akut Hilfe ist klar eben
an die
Einsatzkräfte die wirklich gerade in
Österreich da immer wieder Großartiges
leisten und die sicher eine der der
herausragenden Schwerpunkte das heißt
zwischen Heeres ist das wurde erwähnt
der Bundeskanzler und ich haben und sie
am Wochenende schon darüber verständigt
dass wir auch ganz schnell die Mitteln
aus dem Katastrophen vom mobilisieren
werden es wird auch finanzielle Hilfen
brauchen also gerade dort wo schwere
Beeinträchtigungen gibt und
dass geht aus dem katastrophenfond quasi
die inländische Abteilung hier hervor
dass können wir recht rasch und
unbürokratisch machen und da werden
gerade dann noch die Details fixiert
zweite Frage hätte ich noch und zwar
sollte der Umwelt da Hochwasserschutz
ihrer Meinung nach beschleunigt werden
gibt es da eine Dringlichkeit die jetzt
sichtbar wird ja gut da ist es eine
langandauernde nicht nur Diskussion es
wird ja im Hochwasserschutz in
Österreich ja sehr viel investiert und
verbaut wir haben allerdings die letzten
Jahre viele Jahre eigentlich schon auch
einen glaube ich sinnvollen
Paradigmenwechsel wo und wie hoch
Wasserschutz
angewendet wird weil es gibt ja auch den
passiven Hochwasserschutz wo sehr stark
darum geht viele Flächen die nicht
unbedingt verbaut werden müssen nicht so
verbauen weil dort kommt der dort kommen
ja auch viele Schwierigkeiten her aber
natürlich gibt es insbesondere in
Tälern und in hochgebirgslagen immer
wieder noch
Investitionsmöglichkeiten die aber auch
vorangetrieben werden also die Summen
die hier zur Verfügung gestellt werden
sind sehr groß was haben sie dazu dass
die NGOs jetzt ein bisschen beschuldigt
werden in Hallein im Protesten dass der
nichts gemacht wurde oder die Pläne die
es gegeben hat nicht umgesetzt wurden
ich kenne die Hintergründe erstens nicht
ich kenne schon gar nicht die Fakten
dort also kann ich dazu nicht sagen
und drittens gehe ich davon aus dass
in Österreich alles noch
Genehmigungsverfahren passiert aber wie
gesagt viertens kein kaum ein
kaum ein Erlerntes derart viel in die
das ist ja wahrnehme Vorgänge
Regierungen da muss ich mich ja nicht
damit schmücken aber wir haben uns aus
ökologischer Perspektive immer damit
beschäftigt und es gibt sehr viele
sinnvolle Hochwasserschutzmaßnahmen die
auch finanziert werden
ich darf versuchen dass wir uns die dass
wir die Fragen konzentrieren auf den
Sport es steht da Kommandant des
heeressportzentrums neben mir der auch
Detailfragen beantworten kann und
vielleicht die Fragen zu aktuellen
Ereignissen im Anschlussstellen
wenn es keine Fragen gibt danke ich bin
als wir machen noch bitte eine Frage
noch eine Frage hätte ich noch Frau
Minister die Aufstockung um 20
Leistungssportler Sportlerinnen ist das
auf rübergehender Maßnahme oder ist das
was dauerhaftes das ist jetzt einmal der
erste gesetzte Schritt und wir schauen
natürlich alle Anforderungen die dann da
noch kommen sollten das muss nicht der
letzte sein ich sage das auch ganz offen
wir haben ja in den verschiedensten
Bereichen gezeigt dass das ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt ist im heeressport vom
Grundwehrdiener beginnend eben Schritte
zu setzen und wenn die Notwendigkeit
besteht dann werden wir
selbstverständlich einen weiteren
Schritt setzen heute freuen wir uns wie
gesagt dass wir diese 20 Plätze einmal
garantieren können
ich darf abschließend noch einmal
betonen beim zum Beispiel beim Team für
Tokio für die Olympischen Spiele stellen
wir 50 Soldaten und Soldatinnen darauf
sind wir sehr stolz und wir wünschen
allen
Teilnehmern in Tokio science für
paralympische Spiele oder Olympische
Spiele alles Gute viel Erfolg und
beschließen hier mit den Pressetermin
und wenn uns noch zu den Fotos danke
vielmals fürs kommen wieder Danke schön
danke schön